if you were looking forward to sleeping  dogs - you might be waiting a while I'm  Tony and this gamespot news update is a  bit of a bummer developer United Front  Games has shut down the studio's first  title was 2007 s ModNation racers but  the team is best known for its 2012 hit  Sleeping Dogs most recently the studio  released smash-and-grab on Steam early  access last month but the game has now  completely disappeared from the service  it's unclear why United Front was  shuttered or what will happen to  smash-and-grab now that it's been  delisted we've reached out to the studio  for comment and will report back once we  hear an update for now you can at least  see what smash-and-grab was like by  checking out our coverage on GameSpot  and for all the biggest video game news  you're already in the right place